good evening and welcome to the first
and maybe only racial draft here in New
York City folks this is for all the
marbles
what happens here will state the racial
standing of these Americans once and for
all
that's right and the crowd is here to
support their racism well Rob some of
the biggest names in sports and and
entertainment are on the line tonight
and I'm excited to see who's going to be
drafted by which race seated behind me
on the stage there are the various
representatives and believe it or not
the blacks have actually won the first
pick for me Wow that's the first lottery
of black person's won in a long time
Billy dancing a probably still complain
[Applause]
the most dominant athlete in the world
his father black his mother time well it
doesn't matter anymore because now
the Asians you got to think about it
he's been discriminated against in his
time he's had death threats and he dates
a white woman sounds like a black guy to
me gastly
while hooking black girl red paw I like
to say tremendous opportunity for me
finally be part of a race have a home
been so confused by Kappa clays and so
many things so long fried rice hello
fried chicken
[Applause]
I always wanted to save this for shizzle
well it seems as though Tiger Woods is
happy to be black and that's a good
thing
because I just received word that he
lost all his endorsements oh and mixed
tag heuer wheaties the whole
shebang-a-bang tough break nigga it's
always all right coming up now are the
Jews many have speculated about their
picks I'm guessing they're gonna pick
Madonna and finish off the job Kabbalah
started yes well Rob she was born and
raised Catholic then she became a whore
but over the last decade she has studied
the Kabbalah and she even wrote a
Kabbalah's children's book oh here come
the Jews why don't we take a look
downstairs today we the Jewish people
take Lenny Kravitz actually half-black
and half-jewish his mother was on The
Jeffersons a pivotal show in black
culture and his father a Jew was her
lawyer couldn't make that up Jewish now
unfortunately Lenny can't make it here
too except he's in Miami Beach Miami
Beach well he must have got that news
about being Jewish early all right why
don't we don't take it as future to
their place we the Latinos shoes alien
go solace
I understand that one we wanted to do
this before the white people tried to
adopt him as one of their own then okay
guess whose turn it is white people
let's see what direction they go in
Halle Berry is still available as is
Mariah Carey's crazy ass very mature
rondell
thank you all good afternoon excuse me
pardon me
Hey will you cut the malarkey okay I'm
talking there's a white man talking here
so let's seal
oh now ah thank you damn we the white
delegation are very proud to announce
our pick this year Colin Powell old
Powell is not right he's he's not even
1/8 white he's 100% black last night Wow
I got a wonder how the blacks are gonna
be taking this one black delegation
except the white delegations offered
draft : Paul on the condition that they
also accept Condoleezza Rice as part of
the deal
[Applause]
I need biofuel everywhere we accept got
yourself a goddamn deal
black delegation crest mmm jobs a minute
Roger Park
all right well no hustle me I'm talking
to the ultimate hustler I tell you what
let's make all things fair
we keep Eminem you get OJ Simpson shot
incredible a first round absolutely
chock-full of surprise it's unbelievable
Colin Powell and Condoleezza Rice now
officially white OJ black again think
they would have picked Oprah Oh al
absolutely Rob thick thighs no felonies
she definitely would have been a great
pickup
okay the Chinese delegation is up next
and although they're the last they've
been waiting with a zen-like patience my
guess is young main he's been spending a
lot of time with blacks learning slang
and shit-talking they're not careful
they might lose them the Asian
delegation chooses the RZA the GZA
[Applause]
and choosing the entire wu-tang clan big
BOTS Jokers we've always been a fan of
the Kong food the Chinese coaches
so yo it's like bong bong you know yeah
I wanna remind everybody to diversify
your bonds and Reza's got announcement
to make
oh yeah Oh Dody has now changed his name
from dope Bluecoat to the old dirty
Chinese restaurant konichiwa bitches
we're going there for this incredible
night our coverage ends here but be sure
to catch the rest on our website
congratulations to all the races and
elite you are bitches
[Applause]